[Music]
big announcement so you saw the story
this week that espn had basically fired
allison williams this super talented
sideline reporter college football
basketball they fired her because she
was trying to get pregnant and didn't
want to take a copy 19 vaccine so they
said fine you're out of a job well she's
not out of a job any longer we have
hired her here at daily wire and we are
pumped about it she's going to be
bringing us excellent sports content we
need your help to do this kind of stuff
to help bring people in who've been
thrown out into the cold by the woca
culture go help us out at dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply at
checkout for 25 off we're basically
uncancelling everybody that hollywood
and the leftist machine is canceling and
so we need your help to do that allison
williams has joined the daily wire we
are super excited for her sports
coverage and we're excited to slap espn
in the face frankly dailywire.com
subscribe code do not comply for 25 off
join the fight